I wanna be very careful how I talk about
what us is about because I want to leave
some runway for people to explore what
it means to them it really is a movie
that was made with a a fairly clear
social statement in mind but it's also a
movie that I think is best when it's
personalized it's a movie about the
duality of mankind and it's a movie
about our fear of invasion of the other
of the outsider and the revelation that
are we are our own worst enemy it's not
about drugs it's a dope song don't do
drugs there's a whole collection of
movies about white families dealing with
there goes the neighborhood
two monsters in some kind of you know
weird way one of the things I realized
we never seen was what happens when
there's a black family in the center of
a horror movie
in many ways this movie is not about
race but I do recognize that just the
the fact alone we have a black family in
the center of this movie there's a
completely new palette to how we
experience this horror there's a family
in our driveway who is that
as a result of black people and people
of color being the first sacrifices and
casualties to that genre I usually never
got very attached to that genre itself I
never got to see any kind of
psychological deep development I never
saw any people who looked like me that
were really given a chance to shape the
outcome of the world and shaped the
outcome of this story so it never felt
like something that I could develop an
affinity for because I was never
represented yeah I mean look my whole
thing with the whole black guys the
first to die I don't think that's
exactly accurate I think that it's more
and more the rule is when there's five
people left and one of them is the black
person you know that black person is not
going to be the last one alive the films
never really served us our identity and
people with black skin didn't fare very
well it's just kind of a confusing and
unfortunate thing for me growing up sort
of being in love with horror movies but
also not feeling very well represented
then you know Candyman came along which
is a masterpiece one of the things that
it unlocked is what if the supernatural
killer was is a as a black man watching
get out I got to see the person of color
be the hero the person of color be
resourceful the person of color do
anything that needed to be done to solve
the problem of the movie and then coming
over to us we are now saying all of us
are potentially the problem and we're
caught in a beautiful what if that looks
horrific but I think that's part of the
strength of our movie is that it's
potentially horrific but it's also
world-changing they're 14 minutes away
14 minutes what I was interested in it
was to know what was inspiring
Jordan aesthetically thematically those
kinds of things I really did enjoy tale
of two sisters even though it freaked me
out
it was it's just such a I spent most of
it just peeping from behind a friend's
shoulders you know quite literally it's
the psychological thriller and those are
the ones that cause me the most harm I
think the ones where you're you're your
own worst enemy you know where you don't
know what's real and what's not that
kind of stuff just like weeks me out I
was inspired by the slasher movies I
think I think what people are gonna find
in us is that you know much like an get
out I I'm inspired by many many
different subgenres of horror you know I
really tried to make something that
incorporates what I love about those and
sort of steps into its own new sub-genre
[Applause]
it was taxing or sure because it was
playing two roles in the time I it takes
to prepare for one role but it was also
so liberating you know I think being
able to delve into the darker side of a
person it's it's cathartic and I think
it's actually quite therapeutic too
because you allow yourself to go to some
ugly places and you have permission to
do so you know everything that we would
do so all the sounds the voices we would
be we would have to play the wilson's
looking at our doppelgangers that we may
we might have done the day before and
Jordan would do all of the mannerisms
that we did the day before as the our
doppelgangers imitate the voices and
imitate the movements so it really was
just as shocking as it would be for the
Wilsons to see themselves it was really
shocking for us to kind of see our own
performances because and to see it that
helped us put us in a place of like
sometimes discomfort of like man that's
it it created a really good analogous
situation for the actor and their
character you know there was one moment
I was doing the scene where I was going
through like a labyrinth
type thing and it was just me and I was
I went through the shot whatever and
then on the other end
Jordan sprang out of nowhere and scared
me and I was just like now why would you
do that why would you do that
and then he swore never to do it again
I'm gonna get him back that's for sure
since we've been here they've been
happening more and more I think she's
getting closer my dream has been to have
a varied career and try different things
out horror is something that intrigued
me
you know the few horror films I have
allowed myself to watch in the past few
years I've always been like wow it looks
like it could be a lot of fun to make
those but also do you get scared when
you make horror films I've always been
curious to know what it's like on the
other end and I really love scaring
people like I grew up scared terrorizing
my younger siblings and everything so to
do that on a global scale yes please